I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh
Salam to the people of Marrakesh Salam
membership cards yep go wait for a quote
don't hit your campaigns yep done it on
the way regular videos come on of course
is Salam no you know I was back in the
days you know daily Salam yeah we're on
it
said I'm dining starting soon inshallah
hi dad yeah yes what is it
well I'm going through my list I'm doing
all the checks everything is going well
yeah but I was wondering to myself this
plant look at the ends can you see it's
gone dry rocky and his waterings
disguise you know you do know these
words everything is parallel but look
when have you wanted this plant there
you go
I'm gonna slowly slowly they said is
well if you can't put anything on one
side there's three balance in life you
know brothers and sisters as you can see
this plant in he's working listen Hyder
definitely thought why does it need
watering stay alive the grow to grow did
it was it always as beautiful like this
obviously not was there a stage when it
was little yes there was and it grew and
watch me okay so Bob's and sisters now
where do you guys play role in this
matter well just as a plant and a tree
and flowers and a lot of things in life
need growing I need nutrients and other
things we also a salam need your support
and your help at salaam hamdulillah we
was raising in ramadan 25500 i will
restart Oggy
and as you can see we are produced and
content millions of people are
benefiting and people are falling in
love with our concept Hamden learn all
praises belong to Allah
we've got more amazing ideas to do and a
lot of more things to happen but we
cannot do that we're just having a set
and the studio so we need you guys to
help us inshallah brothers and sisters
please donate the link below Allah and
help us this is our running cost this is
our yearly running costs to operate
and hamdulillah inshallah with the
permission of Allah subhanAllah we want
to carry on our works on a regular basis
where we're going to be having a video
for each day of the week inshaallah
specific programs set for helping our
youth to build their iman and also to
help them love and fall back in love of
islam and in order for us to do that
brother and sisters we need your help
even if you cannot donate share it with
your friends and family and big to offer
us and also even if it's a pound this is
the month of dhul hijjah so hi there
since you like watering plants
i'll leave the last word to you via
postal um hopes that i'll grow and bear
the fruits in the hereafter a
transaction you can never lose